[Music]
Little Liars fans welcome to this week's
edition of the Rosewood rundown once
again I'm Liana gelareh I'm Katy Krause
and boy do we have a show for you we
have interviews with Sasha appear to say
Shay Mitchell and you're re Marlon King
Katie and I were all over the like place
this past week dating content just for
you guys so there's so much I think we
should tease a little bit to what they
can look forward to all right guys we've
asked Marlene Shay and Sasha about the
possibility of an Emison spinoff so
that's going to be at the very end of
the show but we've also asked Shay and
Sasha about Emison baby names and
whether or not we can expect an
engagement in these final two episodes
and you might want to listen very
closely when we do roll that later on in
the show and of course we have some
amazing pretty little flashbacks for you
guys major shout out to Keegan Allen
this week and you guys will find out why
but let's kick things off Katie with our
three biggest bombshells from last
night's episode okay
such a good one yeah let's first start
up talking about Aria salary a shady
girl got caught her friends literally
caught her in the black hoodie listen
they have doom black hoodie which ad is
correct she did look great in the AG
costume um I kind of felt a little bit
bad for aria in a sense because I kind
of do see why she was doing what she was
doing I get that and we had this debate
and and I do I understand her motives
yeah the same time once again she's just
being so selfish well all the girls have
been somewhat selfish in some regard and
they don't have a good point last night
Spencer was on the a-team Toby's been on
the aides name
I mean Lucas slide to the girl look
they've all had their secrets like
they're all liars in one sense or the
other yeah I get that I get that but I'm
still I'm very curious so of course we
saw that Aria brought up an interesting
point last night that we talked about a
couple weeks ago she brought up the
Malcolm issue of it all who here
remembers when Ezra had a son season
three guys season three thanks back with
us guys and when Aria and Spencer were
having their heated
confrontation Aria pointed out you were
on the 18 once
you kidnapped Malcolm and he she was
like that's neither here nor there but
it's interesting that they're trying to
bring it back to that and I don't think
that that's any coincidence and we will
get to that when we get to the pretty
little flashback but should we move on
to a bombshell and number but you
remember two guys Mona and her obsession
with this game what she did talk to us
about last week that the game is going
to kind of take a dark turn in her well
she said that like Mona just really
enjoys challenges and games and like
it's like a drug to her it's addicting
so I loved the little nod that we
thought they were going to see right
here where she so fascinated about it
that she has to pull out what does she
pull out Katie a very nerdy Mona glasses
it's like Inspector Mona I was so great
to like see that throwback because I
know that Jenelle yeah favorite version
of Mona has been nerdy Mona well that's
kind of summing that she's had to deal
with throughout the years I'm pretty
little liars is like not feeling like
she actually fits in yeah that was a
nice callback and I'm excited to see how
that plays out I will say I still don't
think that that means that she is a D by
any means it just means that she's very
smart what did you think about the fact
that Mona called out to the girls and
basically was like oh all right yeah
working out for the ad team and here's
the reasons why you know Aria and Mona
have had a very interesting back and
forth throughout the entire series
they've always had a little bit of
aggression towards each other especially
because Mona dated Mike on the show we
really like get where is my like come
back from team will over here yeah we're
telling Marie Combs and Chad Lowe I hope
we they'll be here for the shinai on the
beach yeah they're still in the basement
but I did appreciate that Mona did not
sugarcoat it she kind of just got it out
on the line she's very smart she was
able to pick all the different pieces
and it kind of goes back to Aria I don't
think she's ad because she's not that
good at it they're not lucky here was my
different thought so when okay the way
that Mona put it was that she
intercepted a call from aria and AD but
when we saw Mona she had that like
really intense little
the phone yeah like which could change
your voice so my thought was like what
if this whole time Aria has thought that
she's been working for the ad team but
in reality this like it's just the Mona
who's been seen as she's a weak link do
you know that was fun
see yeah like it's Leanne guys on Ceres
today know so I still don't think that
Mona is in the ad team but I think that
maybe she's just trying to like test
their their leases yeah yeah I kinda
happening yeah let's move on to our next
bombshell which i think is our favorite
bombshell and hopefully your guys's
favorite I mean you know that Katie and
I are shippers I mean we can I love that
you called it rendezvous in Rosewood the
Rosewood rendezvous is because all hot
GOG is that montage I saw here we go we
got SPO B yeses I always love seeing
Caleb get married and it was so intimate
and private and small and only her mom
was there which I thought was so cute
and sweet
Ezra getting a little action Ezria like
hooking up right after the secret came
out and then he realized here he knew
it's nice to see them actually like get
along and Oh Lucy's favorite thing
backless backless shirt they have fun
when they Philippines and then me and
then I feel like we're about to get into
it there it is Edison guys
the Emison picnic moment and obviously
they took things to the next level last
night anybody ever had a sexy picnic
because minor degree stuff I never that
hot yeah like we did talked to today and
Sasha hey today this morning that's why
we're a little bit later for you guys
but that's because she was getting all
the scoop what did they tell you all
right they were so cute together I think
this is actually one of their only
interviews that they've done together
yeah I think some lounge time was when I
talked to them although years ago any
years ago so this is super funny yes so
you guys have to take a look at what
they said about Emison and pretty please
enjoy I made such a special episode I
understand what is in her favorite part
these last couple of weeks walking this
relationships kind of unfold and grow I
think I'm a fans reaction very so happy
and I
I love right Amundsen yeah and also I
think it was cool for us I'll be like
finally like yeah MSN is together it was
kind of tying everything together and
all the relationships are kind of you
know working out and there's some bumps
but it was really special for Allison so
it's really like admits her her feeling
so it really it was a cool arc for me
and I really really love to plan out and
do it yeah I love that one
we still don't know who the baby's dad
is so how is the identity reveal going
to affect Anacin I mean you know what to
be honest I think the girls have been
through so much with each other you know
separately that I don't really think
anything can take them down so whatever
the result is whoever the dad is I mean
I hope there didn't hurt that much are
we going to get a baby name by series
and and what about an engagement you
know what this is awesome because we
shot good so long I truly can't remember
so it's not even like later I honestly
can't even remember
so really terrible I remember one and
that was that was this we need we need
to look back of course I'm not going to
say it you kidding
I'm secret ok cool how nice it is Odin
but she does remember that one of those
things
yes happen so hopefully that's some news
for you and makes you guys excited
thumbs up this video right now and leave
all your comments of so and there's more
with Sasha and Shay to come later well I
love that you actually ask Sasha about
the Emison baby daddy giv knowing about
that and what she told me I said when
are we gonna find out the truth she said
before the end of the finale and so it
is going to be in that final two-hour
movie so that's very exciting what do
you think it is do you have any ideas at
this point I really don't know you know
it that is the thing like I feel like
Katie and I have cracked the code on so
many of these PLL secrets but that is
the one we're like I really don't know
that it would be and also I don't know
who I would want it to be right someone
did okay I did see a really cool fan
theory that would be cool but also
really creepy and you let me know your
excitement Oh
I think I know your Joe it would be
Jason is the father because even though
that's Ali's brother that means it would
still have DiLaurentis gene so it'd
still be like it was part Ali in part
Emily I don't know how I feel about that
I get that but I don't get that I think
it'd be super creepy but then again this
is a really weird incestuous show anyway
and everyone Jason hooked up with is
what brother yeah maybe Wren I'm going
to take the safe route and say ready go
Heidi run but I really hasn't really had
anything to do except for stock and
airports with creepy you want to be
Spencer that's true uh we chose them a
little bit guys we also asked them about
all the twin theory so we'll play that
shortly for you and also about the
spin-off so let's get into a pretty
little flashback because we're going to
do something a little differently this
week because typically on our pretty
little flashbacks we flash back to early
moments on the show but we are actually
going to flash back to our very first
Rosewood rundown because we have
something from Keegan Allen that we need
you guys to see again and listen to and
then we are going to discuss theories we
as we've we pieced it together we heated
together so so think about this last
night we saw in last night's episode
that Spencer and Toby had a rekindling
she went up to his cabin he didn't know
why she was there and what did they do
Katie big big kiss but take a look at
this look at this and then we shall you
analyze the thing that does end up
happening is there another SPO B kiss to
be expected this is the trouble with
interviewing the people of Pretty Little
Liars is all the answers are I don't
know you'll have to eat I get a lot of
them baby I can honestly say that there
there is not another spoke a kiss I can
honestly say that lies my momís is that
a lie lie I can honestly say that lies
and our search so we thought he was
lying but I think he's telling the truth
I don't think that Spencer and I don't
think he thought it was Spencer last
night either because take a look at this
clip guys yeah I figured that UB and
rosewood keeping tabs on Tanner's case
what's going to happen is going to
happen that doesn't sound like the
Spencer I know surprise it's because I
got Spencer knots phaser at Spencer it's
been here at twin and I don't even see
when she first walked in like Tryon this
is a credit to what a great actress
Tryon is the way she's like looking
around at things and like she's just so
thrilled to be there I think that this
whatever-your-name-is girl cut the bangs
I think that she's always been obsessed
with Toby I think so too and I think
that this Spencer that we saw in this
clip with Toby is very reminiscent of
the airport Spencer with Wren where it's
a little bit of a darker side that you
see it's less makeup it's almost like
this conniving evil and I I think it's
the same girl who kissed him when he was
with LaVon because she mentions that
kiss until the young member that kids to
be shared because I thought that was
really out of character at the time that
was like last season and I actually
tweeted like wow Spencer you being super
desperate right now because that's not
her style at all so I think that that
was the first time that we really saw
the twin take her place I don't know if
you guys agree with us but if you do or
if you don't yes let us know because we
are going to get to our suspect board
later on the show and we want to go
through all of our series and your
theories and talk them all out I really
did one last thing that we saw last
night and if we can roll this clip over
this but look at this scar I think we
were meant to believe that scoffs but
here's the thing I think that that's
where she got shot and that's what
they're trying to show is like oh that's
a new scar and everything they're
lingering on it but I feel like either
she was the one that actually got shot
while she was pretending to be spender
more she also inflicted that to herself
that she will have the same scar right
but I think either way it's going to
mean something and they're trying to
remove his hand - yes very very
interesting guys yeah I'm so excited
really quick before we leave all of our
romance so many comment yeah
I thought it was really funny Jamie said
I just thought it was odd for Caleb to
say we can't testify against each other
and I know she was thinking Jamie but
[ __ ] like I was going to say Ashley but
Hannah right away was like yeah I know
that's another added benefit of us to
get married I think that they were going
to get married regardless it's just a
fringe benefit and I think that was just
a way to say we really do have each
other's back yeah no matter what yeah
and that was just another I don't know
like another layer I don't think that
yeah I don't think it should take away
from you back to that couple got married
it made them endgame yet though
Laila a few more say says Edison endgame
Joanne says she remembers one name does
that mean twins oh she remembers one
thing so she was saying like does she
remember a baby gorgeous you remember if
there's a the engagement she was just
saying she remembers one occur that
either neither the name nor any
engagement happens yeah Liz I'm so glad
that we've introduced you to this ooh
that's a great theory about Spencer's
twin yeah welcome and Lily says okay
what do you think about that okay I
think null is the father of Emily and
Ali's baby you know know was dead before
then before the eggs before and Lonnie
says well okay here's the thing I bet
you no call no con needed money so I
wouldn't be surprised if you're selling
sperm for a while oh that no that's just
real unreal yeah Oh Shay Mitchell hey
girl thanks for driving it's a really
wacky write it up che pazzo exciting why
does she have the scar when we were
talking about Spencer you think the
gunshot I think I let's take a look at
again I feel like it's in the same
location where she got shot so now I
like there's something but good
detective work Shay really good writing
that out we're all the fans who are
watching does it feel fun that shades
watching along with you it must it must
Oh should we get speaking of Shay and
Sasha should we have them there ro test
our eyes at Fast Five as you guys know
we've been catching up with all of your
favorite PLL stars and asking them the
same series of Fast Five questions and
this week it was time for Shay and Sasha
to take the turn yeah take a look one
word to describe the finale
epic shocking shocking how do you feel
about ABS revealed ultimate one one
situation or geysers it anything I agree
honestly the psyche that I don't
couldn't be a better engine yeah what do
you guys think of all the twin theories
that are out there I think everybody can
have a theory but I mean we haven't
really stayed true to any same you know
whether it be in the book or whatever so
always have your own your own theories I
love hearing them but you'll have to
wait and see
yeah you'll have to wait and see and I
think everyone's always wanted to went
the twin theory because of the books but
you know Marlene always districts ever
sleeps so yeah I think it I think it
turned out really well as a fan sternal
of that regardless yes your most
jaw-dropping shocking moments of the
entire series I mean I'd have to say for
me it was his finale table reading yeah
yeah I mean many I know that was like
that wasn't necessarily it was just
really emotional for us but I think the
finale in general was the most I think
yeah Elliot I was hours I know in our a
two hours exactly yeah
what about the first person that you
thought was a honestly yep it could
still be a no you never know um I don't
know I think maybe one of Taryn Lucas I
thought everybody as in a in the show
it's true we yeah anybody could really
knew I knew it was going to be Mona but
that was kind of it until it kind of
happened yeah we were along with the
fans shocked yeah a couple that you
shipped on the show but it can't be
relevant not anything it's our samisen I
would say for me and be hey look
yeah yeah since I can't choose Emison I
always loved so V I watched they loved
Emison also gotta give props I'm
thinking hey lobe is is our winner so
far on that question everybody loved him
the chemistry between miss IO availab -
yeah second - Emerson oh yeah me too
yeah I'm like going through them all
yeah we're not we're not here to rank
them that's true so before we get into
the spin-off yeah very well then I'll go
through series let's bring up our
suspect for depending on your fan
theories guys this is when we were going
to discuss
all Oh Aaron says what if aria has a
twin people keep saying that behind it's
not adding up as much as the Spencer
thing unless they're really building it
up just to completely knock us all down
but I think that in Katy they're talking
about this it's getting a little bit
more and more obvious in these final
episodes which is nice yeah because it's
helping us kind of piece it together
especially with last night and the whole
likes poby moment and he made that
remark like it was such an obvious
remark like that sound like Spencer and
I like the spread sir yeah I know I
think Aria having a twin would be fun
but I don't know that she would be going
down this dark path if it were her that
has a twin yeah and I think that that
would have been a fun degree had it been
earlier on yeah I feel like now that
they've established so much of this one
let's see who else so much love coming
through for Haila I love that Oh Amy
says what about the Emison baby I had a
bath the AMISOM we're going to have
theirs well if you go to each a online
right now there's already information on
the other son baby but there's going to
be even more coming up right now also
we'll say that we didn't play this for
you guys it will be on ET online but we
did ask about we asked Shay and Sasha
about the comment that aria an ad like
their conversation last night of and ad
told Aria much more misery is coming to
your friends and they kind of elaborated
on that a little bit so much misery so
much what did you think about the the
detective coming back last night do you
think that she's actually going to be
able to piece things together I do and
I've always liked detective tanner
yeah I'm very confused though because
what the heck happened to Marco like
where did i'm very just confused in real
life I think he went away to go film the
pilot because he's going to be in a new
ABC show called the good doctor he's all
get away with murder
so maybe scheduling I maybe yeah maybe
just scheduling he couldn't you could
make it but in terms of our fan series
Tina
ooh I think Mona is ad because I don't
believe the whole twin theory ooh
interesting I'm good I want to be angry
okay if Mona turned out to be a Jew I
would he is so fascinated you would like
with because she was a you can't be a
and ad but then it's like a haha gotcha
yeah but like no he's like AD killed her
or with the RA with sec this show I will
say next weekend
we're going to find out who murdered
Charles yes right yes that is something
that we are going into a day out I don't
care I don't really either just realize
that I know I'd rather see more
engagements and I'd rather see my
wedding it's an answer that I want but
like at the same time like I was just
thinking I'm like oh that happened so
long ago that I'd rather tie up other
other end yeah and yes on characters
like we really really love and care that
I'd rather not want to know where Holly
Marie Combs assisted I here no sir I do
too
where she um should we get into this
revenues as Kate and I are talking about
the fact that Pretty Little Liars is
winding down you guys we only have two
episodes left running crazy - that's so
weird
granted we have three hours worth of
content but I was curious Katie was
curious about if a pretty little
spin-off could be in our future so this
weekend I was at the one the only
Marlene King at the ATX Television
Festival in Austin and I took her away
and put her off in a little
interrogation corner and got this
information so take a look a Pretty
Little Liars spin-off a possibility it's
definitely a possibility it's not for
sure thing but there's some ideas
whirling around out there and and
everybody knows I love this world I'd
love to play in this world
I love these characters so it would be
fun to keep a few of them moving forward
in their lives
are there any characters in particular
that you would like to maybe explore
their lives a little deeper yeah but I'm
not going to say just yet who those
characters might be I'm just going to
say I'm just thinking maybe Emison or
Moana and just throw that out there
great idea good idea Smee thank you I
mean they are a good idea yes so then
this morning when we're at the Warner
Brothers a lot also guys if you are in
California I'm just going to say go
check out the Pretty Little Liars made
here exhibit there's a layer you see the
dollhouse you see the creepy masks it's
all in there and you can get tickets
online the one out of Studio Tour which
is the best tour that you can get out
there like you can go sit on the
friend's couch in Central Park this
isn't a plug for that it legitimately
like it'll be fun and I also love hair
a Potter and the Pretty Little Liars
exhibit is mixed in with the Harry
Potter exhibit so in movie 2 you see the
blue car crashing into Rosewood that's
not a lie anyways here's a basic about
the possibility of a sit off
we talked to Marlene earlier this week
and she teased the possibility of a
spinoff would you guys be interested in
an Emerson spin-off for if that were to
happen I mean you never know what could
happen in Rosewood you know that's
always what I say possibly yeah and very
lastly your favorite thing about working
together I mean I never say what you say
- yeah well we can't such a family you
spend so much time together and you're
really up close and personal yeah I saw
the last episode I 5ir like we're closer
than ever I feel like they are all
playing like so coy about it right but I
asked you I think I think that there are
conversations too that are being had
right now let's do real I really think
there are I'm going to ask you guys if
you were to see a spin-off of any
character yeah in Pretty Little Liars
who would you want it to me
I don't even be down to have like a
couple of them like if like Mona was
still involved along with Ali and then
like kind of like maybe like the
Rosewood like not the leftover yeah the
people who still stay in the town
because I have a feeling that people are
after
ADEs finally revealed I know I would be
like I mean out also have Pretty Little
Liars a movie maybe in a few years but I
feel like yeah I think I can only a
couple years because Marlene had told me
that this really is her movie this
two-hour finale is her movie also Katie
I didn't tell you I asked Marlene how
the Emison baby storyline came to be
what did she say so you catch
misinformation dude because I wanted
your genuine reaction right now so I was
like honestly how did this like absurd
storyline come about and she said that
it was their new producer who came in
this final-season Charlie Craig came
into the writers room was like I have an
idea you're either going to love it or
going to throw things at me and he
pitched the idea and Marlene had them
all think about it we may resonate to
you our yes and they wanted to like
sleep yet I may want in it sleep on it
and then they're like yes that is it and
I read your story
I need to tell it to you in person I
know I read yours too we're cc we're
like we're like che and they just love
each other
well my fans of each other's worth we're
still getting in Seoul oh yeah a few
more before we wrap up Oh Karin says I'm
with you I want to see more weddings oh
yeah here's my tiny little pet peeves
okay I would have loved to have seen
Hannah in a wedding dress or at least
well especially cuz Ashley Benson I feel
like she's such a fashionista so I would
have loved you right to see her and I'm
wetting I dress really wonderful when
her mom brought her that bouquet but
like had she just like brought her like
a simple white gown like that to me
would run great I know that the
romanticism was it was on the fly and
like super far away Mary just hayla
Bleich yeah are very just amount about
each other they're not about the big
production so I did and I guess that but
I feel like she was like a little JYP's
because like I love that couple so much
and if the Ezreal wedding is this giant
grandiose affair I'm just going to be a
little bummed a few more Oh Sandra says
she wants a halo but spinoff and
Michelle says a show from the
perspective of a or ad would be a great
that would be really fun
Chrissy says I think detective Tanner
saying quote I've always felt like
you've been involved I just don't know
how to Spencer is another hint to the
twin theory I love that John McCarthy
and I'm also Erica says it's Ezra it's
got to be nothing else makes sense do
you really think here's the thing I
wouldn't be mad if it was Ezra I would
be here at Marcy okay and Dad yeah and
like that whole book thing and then that
kind of got closed last night in my
opinion with the whole police report
situation so I don't know how I would
feel about I feel like my main thing is
as we approach these final two episodes
the one thing that I'll be really upset
about is if I can go back and be like
what is the n80 Club what is this like
do that and if I have the NAPL I have
legitimate lingering questions I'll be
upset but the great thing is that
Marlene has promised that we will have
all the answers there is one thing that
Mona said or not Mona Janel Parrish said
to us last week that we asked her about
we said the whole New York shooting
situation member aria and one hour
we don't know we're ever going to get an
answer to that maybe we will read what
that she got away with murder dad you'll
be on cam to think that we would get no
yeah I thought if that was in the throw
away yeah yeah it was it was yeah maybe
we should work on a story about all the
answers afterwards that we still know oh
we're going to be working on it so many
things for you guys you guys have no
idea Kate and I have no lives for the
next two we know they're gearing up for
the Pretty Little Liars finale yet he ll
make sure you guys keep it locked out to
ET online we will put more of our
interview up with Sasha and Shay and
Marlene we are working on another
special guest for next week working on a
couple special guests and I think that
you guys will be happy because I'm
thinking we're going to be getting a lot
of answers yes thank you guys so much
for tuning in
make sure you keep tweeting us your fan
theories can we can include them in the
show I'm at Leanna Aguilera and at Cady
underscore Krause and I know why that
took me a second to my banana sweater
and smell good hey our brain is filled
every yeah right right now thank you
guys all so much for tuning in to the
Rosewood rundown we adore you so much
and thank you so much with you next
Wednesday bye guys
you